dire la numéro 2 ça gâteau proue avec un
homme qui fait un strip tease dans la
rue ah oui vous avez déjà un mec qui
nous a fait un striptease avant oui non
c'est pas vrai c'est la tristesse
inexcusable est-ce que sexy quelqu'un un
mec fait un strip tina oui on a dit que
les banques allaient pondre de la mer
qui sait que j'ai tellement de poils la
personne ne soit pas si je suis encore à
biovail a parlé confessionnelles même
entre été acculé stripteaseur
professionnelle mais quand tu te font en
amateur c'est chic fou rire madame est à
vous ah c'est pas comme si vous êtes si
mon amoureuse mais fait un striptease
moi je pars en fois là je suis sur
benjamin castaldi a déjà fait un strip
tease à une de ses fans alors voilà papa
pour ça qu'elles sont comparés à une de
mes femmes n'ont acquis élan qui a pas
d'autre il met toi non quoi alors à
l'annoncé de ce cessez quand j'avais vu
quand je faisais du strip tease pour
gagner ma vie non non ce qui me croient
pas réceptifs abonnement ça m'est arrivé
mais oui si je voyais des gars laissant
des messages fait parce que là on dirait
que nous sommes ainsi qu'au liban
mais en fait parce que j'aime bien c'est
de descendre le slip
ouais je sais ça remonte eloi longueur
chaussettes de la colle si vous avez
l'adresse de cette école ne l'est pas
oui moi moi prime de risque qu'un sketch
entre les deux camps merci bah écoutez
c'est la même école non mais ça se
propage pas à dire ça peut arriver comme
ça perd la confiance alors agathois il
ya déjà mais qui vous avez un strip
tease
mais j'en voulais qu'il fasse beau monde
donc c'est vrai mais quand c'était
effectivement un peu ridicule mais des
coups c'est attendrissant
bah ouais ça m'a pas fait rire je vous
avais déjà patrie piaf à tous oui parce
que je suis assez sensuelle dans
[Rires]
il n'a pas tout oui je vous dis oui mais
la longue ça a l'air de vous étonner
ah ouais classe et sensuelle j'ai un
beau corps donc comme ça quand je suis
bien lancée c'est chaud allez on va de
20 c'est n'importe quoi
vous vous êtes bien maintenant je mets
la vie pas très sexy oui mais non je me
suis parfois garder sous fait de sexy
boy a lâché folates à la cua et
chipolatas les brochettes au barbecue
oui c'est ça tu serais bon cuisine à
face aussi de m'améliorer chaque jour un
peu à ça pas sexy adapté de tuniques et
les tuniques way you lie qui s'adresse à
tunis à la mi-août habillement mais vous
dites à personne voulait faire la
manette ou à lens en double
[Rires]